now the parts of oneself that unites
with God is of course not the body or
any kind of any part of the material
aspect of one's self but it's only the
intellectual self the the it is the
intellect that unites with God so the
human being insofar as the intellectual
part of the soul is concerned is a kind
of spark of the Divine whereas his
material body or the material world in
general is the very opposite of this
employing the Divine names of God and
letters of the Hebrew alphabet to become
unfettered from the world of matter and
body and instead the actualization of
the Soul's intellectual aspect until one
reaches the experience of De vacut of
cleaving to the active intellect and
ultimately as we have seen to God
himself until the two have become one
and he is he you can see why he would be
a somewhat controversial figure